les copains
les fonds jeunes la night ce camp le
portefeuille juge mme wright ceux pour
qui la mouise saf le rite le jour on
rockin guise de frissons dans les
copains
okani ce conte des safiots
et qui font des magne à la veuve
clicquot ceux qui comptent les heures
sur leurs pattes on est con une demeure
pour y planquer jours
c'est une chanson que j'avais écrite au
moment où j'avais déjà vu un hibou et
lui il pouvait mort et veulent enterrer
j'ai fait cette chanson je les
envelopper dans dance est dans ce
manuscrit des copains de l'année y est
me souviens c'était la campagne à trois
mois après j'ai été déterrés j'ai
regardé si rester quelque chose j'ai
trouvé qu'une ou deux plumes la terre
avait tout bouffer le hibou et et la
musique la terre bouffe tout
heureusement les copains de la farce ou
même pas de fait pour fo tient gars ou
pour y danser ce qui pousse la lourde
dès minuit passé et qui n'ont qu'en
gourde que celle du tout lié les copains
la frime ceux qui vendent de vent
à des prix minimes on ya des clients
ce pool a vibré comme la fleur des
champs et qui vis ton rêve pour gagner
du temps
les copains du soir les frangins de la
nuit ceux qui bossent noire jusqu'aux
planches
ce conte la vie louche comme un beau
matin et qui se posent la bouche
en cause un des mains les copains nanou
le frangin de la nuit au matin des
feuilles de tous leurs habits le petit
jour canaille les prend par le coup et
puis les ont pas eu d